les châteaux de la loire vue du ciel
c'est un privilège que même les rois qui
les ont fait bâtir n'ont pas connu une
expérience inoubliable et qui tend à se
démocratiser pour quelques centaines de
francs il est possible de survoler en
ballon en avion ou en hélicoptère les
plus beaux châteaux de france on décolle
au dessus de chenonceau et de chambord
avec françois vallet et mathieu dreujou
ça ne s'est même pas cinq minutes
l'hélicoptère a décollé et déjà la
touraine est à la verdure et ses
richesses ou des tours du cher le
château de chenonceau 16e siècle
gilbert le pilote commente la visite à
200 mètres d'altitude tout semble à
portée de main au bord de la loire cette
fois tout mon ancienne forteresse sans
s'être construite cap à l'est
amboise et son château où françois 1er
mai accueillir son ami leonard de vinci
tous ces châteaux maurice jacques et
annette les connaissez bien parce qu'ils
habitent la région
mais c'est la première fois qu'ils les
voyaient du ciel c'est mon anniversaire
alors c'est les enfants qui m'ont offert
ça pour mon anniversaire la merveilleux
un bon souvenir
nos frais comme un bon resto exactement
enfin non plusieurs bons restos quand
même nos vacances intérêt tellement mon
parcours est dans une petite maison un
petit but
la proximité des châteaux rend le luxe
plus abordable de 350 à 1453 personnes
suivant les six tués sur le circuit de
chambord on voit à peu près 12 château
12 grands châteaux sur un seul circuit
ce qui est énorme et sans compter tous
les petits chapeaux privé qui a écouté
je dirais que les clients déjà le fait
de monter dans l'hélicoptère sont déjà
impatients mais comment ne pas être
impressionné avec chambord à vos pieds
et pour finir le charme d'un palais
disparu le château de choiseul démonter
pierre par pierre au xviie siècle par
des pillards seul subsiste la pagode de
44 mètres de haut preuve que nos
ancêtres m et déjà prendre de la hauteur
pour contempler leurs terres